[Music]
good morning good afternoon good
evening wherever hell you are in the
world welcome to sidetrack your sci-fi
tv a movie channel and welcome to the
25th anniversary of sg1 appearing on our
screens in in america not in the uk but
we were growing up
welcome to matt the blurry dean he's
still very blurry um am i still wait why
am i blurry i don't know my side you are
no it might be my internet signal but
anyway welcome matty how are you doing
sir
i am good really really good how are you
all
very very well how are you all of us
over here
so
hey gators how are we doing
it's a bit of a red letter day
it's 25th anniversary about one of our
favorite shows we want stargate campaign
is kicking off this evening
in one hour we are going to ask you to
go on to twitter and wherever the hell
you
go on
and use the hashtag we want stargate
stargate hashtag we want bradgate
whatever the hell you want use all of
them if you'd like
and we're going to absolutely [ __ ] all
over amazon and we're going to insist
on stargate to return a good stargate
hopefully matty you are ready you are
going to be giving us uh reports on how
we're getting on with i am stormgate so
um it's not just a twitch storm by the
way you can start twittering right now
i'm going to pretend like i understand
what twitter means
and why it does
not a clue
do you want to tell us a bit about
what's actually going on this evening
yeah so in an hour's time everyone is
going to well hopefully everyone
everyone watching this
shall be
going onto twitter facebook basically
any social network you've got tumblr
whatever
using the hashtag we want stargate if
you use an image it should boost it up a
little bit more so what i've been doing
is having like little memes
like of teal saying indeed and you know
things that stargate fans will
appreciate having those which people
will interact with and like
and retweet and to help it push push up
a little bit more the more you tweet the
more the hashtag is found on twitter the
higher the chances of it trending now it
has been
being tweeted a lot today because it is
the 25th anniversary but it's still not
trending so we're hoping
that in an hour's time when the tweet
storm or tweet event it's not called a
storm anymore when it happens
that concentrated rush of people
tweeting it all at once will push it
into trending and amazon will see it and
go
okay here's stargate and we can all live
happy ever after we'll be happy ever
after let's go stargate what i'm gonna
do mate because you are blurry i'm just
gonna kick you out a sec and i'm gonna
put you back in because maybe that's
done it so one sec okay
say bye
so yeah the uh amazon is a bit of it no
that's made no difference whatsoever
mate i don't know if you log out and log
back in maybe it's your internet so but
you're a fighter
you're fine i'm [ __ ]
we need to get matt blurry trending yes
so i'll tell you what while we're on i
will just invite our other mate steve
who
is ready to go a minute i'm good
i i look at you fully dressed yes i am
i'm just for action i've got me that as
well
no
it looks like a
a a man let's have fun with that
did it work
welcome to steve hey look you're not
looking this bad now i'll repeat 90.
don't start with me
you are ready to go sir i am sorry just
to introduce everybody to steve from
that yorkshire git no not
i think you were like first time i think
we've had a few heat discussions once or
twice and i thought
no we've had a very friendly debate
somewhere once or
twice i've got some uh strong feelings
about certain things but we'll not go
into that tonight
no don't worry this is all about
stargate but okay i i know all about
yorkshireman and if you didn't have
strong feelings i would assume you
weren't really from yorkshire so hey the
british eh but no tonight is about
stargate so look
why steve is with us is and anyone else
can join um with us tonight if you want
to come on and tell us about why you
want stargate to return you can message
me either on twitter or you can message
me through facebook it's jamie rickson
on facebook the description it's in the
description you can link and i can send
you a link and you can come and tell us
all about why you want stargate if you
want to so please do but while you were
the steve
why am i you're on youtube channel
that you'll
get which is we're sticking with
your geek please guys go and subscribe
um you do reviews every week don't you
about
all yeah like the oval and star trek and
you know anything that interests me
basically i do a review of um
uh i'm not very good at it but i do my
best
i've invited you before and you didn't
want to come because you said i'm not
ready and you but you're here so let me
in now yeah yeah i'm dressed ready to
fight i get i don't get a bit
tongue-tied at times but yeah i muddle
through
i've been doing this for five years now
and i still struggle to say sentences
so every so often somebody going are you
you skipped on your words yes words are
hard
leave me alone
but
for a bit of fun before we get stuck in
too much
i got a little quiz book for you steve
so
ready oh no not a quiz say when where my
brain exit stage lift say when i'm gonna
go probably as bad as me steve
[Laughter]
stay away
go you're right okay so that's picked a
page for you
i'm going to go through the first one i
see
this race of aliens were the first host
of the gold world and of course problems
on several sg-1 missions even without
being blended
what species
oh
those are the episodes i always skip for
some reason i've never liked the ooh nas
i always skip over those episodes we've
always got a couple of episodes i might
do a video in a couple of weeks about
which stargate videos does everybody
want to skip
because i've got a couple
but i just think
they're doing that one
i love the poker episodes i end up
skipping
fast forward all the bits in between
which is not on
my wife's not watching
uh kevin mccabe got in there with the
unass he knew he knew jackadan no it was
a eunice well done guys
so why steve so just tell us what you
wanted to come on steven and you want to
tell us what stargate 25th anniversary
we want stargate why do you want to see
a new series of stargate come back
well it's one of my favorite series it's
up there with star trek um
probably what's more stargate than star
trek to be honest but um
i have written down a little a little
note why i love stargate because i
thought if i just come in unprepared
i'd make a mess of it so i've written it
down so here we go say i love stargate
because it's set in the here and now
uh it doesn't show evolved humans you
know like we've seen star trek you know
suppose we evolved
exploring the galaxy being perfect and
egalitarian
it shows imperfect modern humans like we
are today doing their best in the galaxy
with as many bad guys as good guys
it isn't some far-off future where we
have strived to achieve amazing
technologies it's set now where we have
acquired technologies from out there
and we don't know always know how it
works properly uh you know we muddle
through yeah we've got geniuses like
rodney and sam carter that uh
seem to know what they're doing but i
think a lot of the time it's guess work
in it
um
it shows how 21st century humans can
affect change in the dangerous universe
by fighting for freedom and the
individual yet using amazing teamwork to
achieve incredible goals
and i love the characters created by the
franchise and the humor that weaved
through the series yes including
stargate universe
yeah and i love stargate because it's
fun even stargate universe will form
towards the end
we're doing
we're doing a couple of videos at the
moment where matt picks one side of the
argument and i pick the other
this week we've done um stupid other uri
and awesome of the aura and we should be
out tomorrow yeah next week it's uh
very very uh polarizing subject
obviously
[Laughter]
i just started rewatching season nine
season nine and ten controversial my two
favorite seasons of sg sdg-1
i think so i i think it might be my
favorites yeah the one the ones i
re-watch most
i'm not sure
but not for the aura i like them because
of the whole merlin thing i hated the
moonlight thing i love them i i love the
i love the ancients that's it i love the
ancients yeah yeah okay
so it's the humor for me as well though
that i missed in universe that's what i
missed
um and i this is one of those things
a lot of those things that you mentioned
is what i'm worried about for the new
series i don't want to see a new series
that
um is star trek instead of stargate
which i did a video about this a little
while ago i'm a little worried that
we've acquired so much technology now
and brad wright's already said that he
wants it to be
the secret to be out everyone's gonna
know about the gate so i'm like
it's becoming stargate it's gonna start
trekker on the stargate it's it's not
that
there's always that thing about stargate
wasn't it this could be happening and
that's all of a sudden it's like the
bubbles burst it can't it can't be
happening
you know that's my worry that's my thing
which is a lot of people say let's do a
hard reboot and just start again and i'm
like i don't i don't like that but
but but then thereby it's like my
emotional brain says no i don't like it
i want i i want canon but then my like
practical brain goes so i'll be a lot
[ __ ] easier i don't know if they just
started again
and i like the idea of we have all this
technology but we're pretty stupid
as a species so at some point during the
last 10 years we've just lost it like
it's where is it i don't know let's be
honest or something like that and we
just we could just have we just have to
start again
like we've lost the asgard core where is
it
i put it down
and i'll prevent someone why did the
asgard
look after everything of the you know of
theirs
i know literally within the first five
minutes the ship got blown up and we
have to go back in time to fix it
no i'm with you on that one i'm not sure
if i was the oscar but the ice god love
just didn't know they loved o'neill
anyway
but um
no i said that there are there are i do
have concerns about a new series but
um
i do think brad wright's obviously got
an idea of where he wants to go with it
and other than sgu
i do trust brad
i just i
like we all know i've said this
repeatedly i'm not a fan of sgu
it was getting better it was
but i just thought it was funless
there was no joy to it
um and i think they got the characters
other than eli and rush i thought the
characters were a bit forgettable but
i actually did a video about sgu and i
tried to remember all the characters and
then i went back and looked at the imdb
and i was like i forgot about half of
them
my favorite character from sgu
is the character that everyone would
have probably forgotten but it's again
do you know again well she didn't last
long did she she didn't
the the lovely redheaded lady
from the illusion of the lucy and the
lions oh yes yes because i'm watching
i'm re-watching sgu at the moment and
i've just got on seasons i'm on like
episode 11 of season two now but she she
literally just died
and i feel like there was some of these
polite even in it mate i've forgotten
all about that so i i i was watching it
again i am watching it again i started
watching again because i did a video
slagging it off and people were no give
it another chance so i watched it again
and i loved the first two you know the
first it's like three-parter in the
start the first episodes are great and
i'm like oh my gosh this is like having
new stargate i forgot how good this is
and then in the third episode i went oh
yeah i remember now
this is boring
it's like when i started to you know
with all those blue rocks and things and
this is door
and then it would have been to you know
oh we're lost and we're far away from
war weasels week after week when it was
like that yeah
exactly but it it was getting better
towards the end but my main problem is
they never had a decent i'm she'll say
protagonist matches to annoy people
so
can't believe we both made the same
mistake uh antagonist they never had a
decent antagonist
um
we want jim let's get her back who's the
um soldier the female soldier with the
really big boobs
sorry to be very mad about this
yes
she had a thing with a crazy sergeant
whose name's gone out mad
great
no in nsga it wasn't great was it at
first you were we first seen
out in a closet out there with uh
lieutenant um
handsome
yeah somebody will get into the
she had she was very she's very
pretentious baby boobs
sorry for the ladies present but men
think about things like that and we
shouldn't it's badass i preferred uh
tamara johansen
tomorrow i never liked her really i
looked a bit like um think you've gone
all blurry again your internet is
rubbish this evening
um
i've got no idea why i'm not running
anything
your camera disagrees
but hey it's because it's a big night so
it's obviously going to be a bit crap
but um maybe it's because i've got all
these tabs open
and then i've had complaints about my
microphone and i've got a new one so i'm
very happy about that and it seems to be
working which is a good bonus
so
steve i never asked when when a new
stargate series comes in what sort of
things do you want to see what what what
would be what's important to you what
are they
well i'd like to see a continuation of
you know what we've had before so i
don't want to see a reboot let's take a
continuation um
but if they want to you know have new
things then fair enough you know change
it up a bit but don't forget everything
that's gone in the past you know let's
have
cameos from past
um characters you know like salmon and
and jack and all these and all these uh
pop up every now and again but they
don't have to be you know main cast
uh uh i'd still like it to be
i don't want it to be um
public knowledge you know i'd still like
it to be secret
because you know we've we've got to have
a secret beer something in cheyenne
mountain so
i don't want it i don't want the stagger
to be in the middle of a mall you know
like it were in uh that episode uh will
it 2010 however
yeah um
we're making this all sterile one for
that episode
um
i don't want to say that i still want to
still want to be secret and i still want
soldiers going through on missions um
doing cool things and fighting bad guys
and i want there to be a new big bad
uh something that we've never seen
before maybe connected to a baddie that
we've seen before you know maybe a new
sort of gold or a new sort of
you know ascended being or something
like that
yeah um
but yeah that's what i want it to be fun
i don't need to be miserable like
stargate universe well at the beginning
yeah or how star trek is now and yeah
yeah yeah like
strange new worlds strange new worlds
it's got a bit of fun about it yeah
that's a lot of people change new worlds
that's great is that yeah i love them i
just in the episode was i've started
watching again it must be good cause i'm
a second time around um but when um
uh captain pike's going ah doing a
pirate impression
i just i'd love that i just that was my
that was just just cracking um
so yeah
there's bits of i don't like strange new
worlds but on the whole the characters
are so good it makes up for any
shortcomings it's just it's just great
um what did you think about my idea both
of you actually did you see my video
where i said the bad guys should be the
furlings
yes did you see that video yeah what did
you guys think of that idea because it
was my idea that's that's not me being
told anything you know i didn't have
people i speak to they tell me certain
things little
that's not based on that that's just my
opinion what did you guys think
and you don't have to be nice if you
think it's just stupid they're just
there's a stupid idea no it's not a bad
idea to be honest because we don't know
anything about the feelings do we
you know people think oh that he walks
and i once got into a
jokey conversation saying that the
furlings are the mummers and their cats
[Laughter]
they've evolved into cats which is why
they're rulers
i did get a comment saying um you're a
bloody idiot how are we going to be
scared of little teddy bears yeah i mean
that's not what they really look like
you need to go back and watch the
episode
i didn't play in the video
there's so many people that don't don't
know that the 200 episode was a joke
episode
no
um he's a big fan of stargate but i
think he might be trying to wind me up
um but no they're not fluffy and cute we
don't know anything about them at all
not really um so i just i just like that
idea because everybody wants to know the
feelings i just think that could be an
interesting twist everyone's just
screaming about could be the stupid
nightmares wouldn't they yeah yeah well
let's get them in a good reason why they
could be the bad guy because you know
nothing about them and you think they're
a good guy just because they're in the
alliance because you're in an alliance
with someone doesn't make you good
now and i want to see him doing like a
twist where it's like um
a thanos type of thing where he the
furlongs don't think they're the bad
guys they think they're doing the right
thing for some reason or or they think
they're doing something they think but
it's we have to like go no it's wrong
don't kill half the universe you that
you know the other half can live great
or you know the vorlands at the end of
babylon five where they're the good guys
all the way through and then there's a
big twist and we had to fight i want to
see something like that i think they
could be quite clever with it but they
could do it where that
um those humans the tory tower however
the hell you pronounce it um
we've we've done too much we've done too
much damage we've progressed too quickly
with the technology that we've been
given about the asgard and what we've
got from the
ancients and all that
we've progressed to too quickly and
we're causing damage and the furlings
step in to stop it oh i like it what a
good idea
maybe we
we're not using the technology wisely
you you've spoken for brad aren't you
jay won't you
message him and tell him the idea
he didn't get the code
i want to credit
well oh yeah that was a good one i like
that uh now um i said something that was
turned out to be kind of incorrect brad
told me offer it and that i shouldn't
have shared
so um so yeah i've been told off a
couple of times by brad
oh well never mind um
oh yeah yeah exactly you should be
thanking me i'm talking i'm like i say
i'm i'm single-handedly getting stargate
back on the airwaves i am totally
giant freaking robot can take credit if
they want to
i want some so single-handedly fighting
it's just you the person who doesn't
know how to use twitter
i don't even know what it's for
i'm on twitter and i don't know why
i'm like why is it why am i why am i
allowed to do so many letters does this
make sense what's going on here it's
they won't let me finish my sentence
stupid thing
okay yeah that's all going red
i don't know man this is this is why
you're on the team
because you know how stuff works
i don't
but i'm good at talking [ __ ] as i said
earlier what you're looking for is a
nerd
and that's why you're here welcome
but i can talk crap olympic standard so
and that's why i'm here so uh but yeah
i i can't wait so what what do you think
steve and matt but steve first as you're
our welcome guest this evening um do you
think things like this social media
twitter storm and matt you'll have to
give us an update in a second let's have
a look at the numbers um do you think
this sort of thing can work
i think
it can't do any am can it um
i think it could work you know i'm sure
the amazon executives um
they may not
know about it initially but they'll be
told about it there'll be people in
amazon that will be paying attention to
this sort of thing whether
so you know the
the higher up guys they'll get to know
the ones with the money they'll
they'll get to know that you know the
fans have spoken so hopefully you know
yeah give it a bit of impetus so we'll
see there's an impotent for a second
oh oh i impetus uh sorry now that makes
more sense
my medical problems
we get for an age don't we steve
uh how about you matt who's a young
whippersnapper you have no impotent
problems dear you're all good in you
i think so yeah
what do you think yeah
definitely could work it has to really i
mean it worked for the expanse why not
stargate
it's a way bigger than he expands
well yeah exactly i would say it's
already worked once we had um a big
twitter storm into 2019 and then just
after that i mean mgm ordered brad to
write her
um right script so i would say i mean
obviously then covered him it didn't
happen but it was supposed to i said
what i'm told is it was it was literally
that close to getting green lit when
covered hit
and they were they were right on it
i i sent messages down to the people i
speak to that that helped me out with
these things and um two or three people
have come back to me said yeah they get
reports on this sort of thing so there
was already they do social media reports
at amazon uh regularly about what is
trending and what is thing and they they
i don't know where they get the numbers
from it's probably something like what
you're using today to sort of track this
first
sophisticated ways of doing it but they
end up with um percentage points
about how much content but they even
apparently know
how much is positive and which is
negative so they have something like
like oh you use probably ai to determine
yeah so what's positive what's nice they
even know um exactly what's going on
sort of thing so i mean
they are listening
and amazon i think are the company at
the forefront of
this type of metadata
you know they they have strong
relationships apparently with facebook
and and looking at and and things like
this and they they yeah they do watch so
i would argue these things i would
actually not only has it worked before
it can work again so
in 35 minutes start pounding twitter
yeah i think i think the i think it's
working already uh based on what i can
see so give us an update quick
disclaimer
i'm using the twitter api to basically
scrape
um
tweets that have have we once targeted
right i'm limited to only 900 every time
i run it so i run it like once i've run
it twice today so i've got two data
points the first time i did it
i basically looked at how many tweaks we
had so about 900 and then how many
retweets
in total so it was about 10 000 retweets
and this was about
three o'clock so what three four hours
ago
ish
yeah
i took no it wasn't until three o'clock
it was probably like two one or two
o'clock anyway i did it again half an
hour before we started this stream and
the
same amount of tweets
but it is now 20 000 retweets so they're
going to be looking at things like that
as well that how many people are
actually actively engaging with it
not even including the twitter storm
which i'll pull tomorrow because i can i
can only do the last 24 hours i can't do
it hour by hour
so that's tomorrow and i'll see what it
what it is but
easy
if it's doubled in like three or four
hours without the tweetstorm it's gonna
easily double again i reckon with the
tweetstorm to about 40 000 retweets
or cause i cannot as i said i can only
pull 900 tweets at a time so it's a
really small subsection of what's
actually going on but that subsection
tells a lot
yeah it's that's just like how they
uh
when we have party politicals you know
we have votes in this or they take a
small section of the vote and we can
tell us what this bigger section is
doing so okay cool so that's only
increased massively so you're not going
to give us any major updates as we go
along then which is a shame
no
i've got the trending list open and it's
updating live so if it pops up and it's
there i can say we're trending and
we can party but beyonce let's hope we
get that today then so let's see how we
get on uh i can tell you that let's just
look at my twitter store it's we want ah
i'm just retweeting this one there's
antara macmillan who is just a lovely
lady and she um is twitter but she's got
herself it's another picture with a big
board saying we want stargate
and um and she's she's just put it on
with brad wright with brad wright that's
the important thing i actually think
that um people need to
um
well brad wright's just tweeted as well
happy 25th versus stage 21 thank you to
everyone who's been asking mgm members
and bring stargate back with amazing
fans like you i'm sure they will it's
already had 454 likes 150 retweets
and he is actually tweeting hashtag 25th
sg-1 anniversary
and stargate sg-1 brad
you know peter williams
yeah so this is a fan moment for me i
tweeted him this morning saying it's for
25 years ago today we met our lord the
one true system lord apophis and he
tweeted me back and it was great
but he is also tweeting we want stargate
so we've got some of them on board
damn right damn right
um joseph melosi we want stargate and
he's tweeted out the um the opening
sequence with the cross side
um i can't go cross-eyed there we go
with a cross-side um
sarcophagus
he tweeted that 25 minutes ago
um
baron destructor
everyone's getting on board everyone
every
every single tweet i'm looking at is
stargate stargaze stargate
so family hug don't know what that's
about and then stargate and some of your
images
like that
how how is my camera
who did that picture
well that's not ready that tweet has got
like nearly a hundred retweets
might be that one because i've posted a
couple of times now but the original
tweet almost a hundred i'm so proud
well that image has done very well i've
been tweeting it all day
um
our copy of um tv week from stargate sg1
from back in the day everyone's gonna
like say it's all over twitter at the
moment
i'm retweeting everything i can
so in half an hour if everyone
everyone
does a proper concentrated burst and i'm
talking you tweet once you tweet twice
you keep on tweeting
to the point where you look like a
spammer
keep doing that
with images and your favorite moments
about stargate it's gotta work it's
gonna be
i know
i know for a fact
amazon wants to bring back stargate it's
one of the reasons why they bought mgm
it's the second highest grossing
thing they own it's own bond is the only
more profitable
franchise individual actual franchise i
mean they got rocky which is is a bit
different but um it's the most
profitable thing they own
they're going to bring it back it's just
whether we get brad or not that's the
only thing that that should be the
campaign should be really do we want
brad back
yeah
looking at the sentiments in most on the
tweets because i i'm looking at the we
once targeted
a lot of people i said i don't know the
actual data and whatnot but it does look
like most people are asking for brad so
they must see that as well
yeah right
just to go back to this then
matthew this time you go
stop stop
oh for god's sake it's the same page
[Laughter]
there we go how do you think right this
is like magician shuffles where you just
it's always that page
yeah
exactly right so whoever says first and
then get into the comments as well
um
colonel o'neill became leader of sg-1
after o'neill
which colonel became leader of sg-1
after o'neill retired for the second
time
make peace
what say
colonel make peace yes
well done colonel make peace steve you
got beat there might want another go
uh
because i'm pretty sure that's the story
where he he has to he gets sacked
because he steals something from the um
the tollen you know yeah yeah yeah
i recently watched that episode
in the episode touchstone where was the
touchstone missing from what what did
they steal it from
uh wasn't it like a statue's hand
it was a stat why weren't you this good
when we did an sg1
[Laughter]
i did that quiz and you didn't know a
damn thing do you remember that
was that that one with the weather thing
yeah oh he was rubbish
it all goes down here from here
yeah we'll have one more before we start
getting into the things we'll finish the
quote
but we also saved your little butts from
the replicators
little gray butts
you've got your little grey pot handed
to you there sir but you've got your
heavily armed so you could just
kill him
if you wanted to
but steve it has been absolutely
amazing having you on board um please
everybody go and subscribe to
the yorkshire git no the yorkshire geek
who does
lots of really brilliant comment uh
videos everyone and if anybody else
wants to come and join us
get in there message me nobody has so no
one's coming on yet but if anybody wants
to please do
okay
thank you very much for having me on
it's been a blast please come back any
time because i would love to do a proper
video with you okay
no
any time you've got something you want
to talk about or someone moan about or
you want to argue about woke because
that could be a very interesting video
yeah so let's do that i like an argument
a debate debate
debate
um
we won't just shut up matt and we were
i'm so doing that t-shirt we're sure
every opportunity i get but steve thank
you very much um anybody watching the
video i haven't put a link on your
channel just yet but i will put a link
on your channel in the description a
little bit later and i'll
i will put a link on our um on my
community page for you as well so go on
there and have a look
okay thank you very much
until next time i'll see
i don't know what that means
oh he's a good man i didn't understand a
word he said um
i did he's lovely um there's his channel
in the uh in the comments
oh thank you very much sir thank you
very much right um it's not about if
everyone agrees andrew you are right but
it would be a lot easier if everyone
agreed with me
that would make things a lot easier um
and
it's no fun is i think people get
stressed sometimes because they think it
starts
um
i can still hear you
um
i think it's um there's the there's the
video like say
the yorkshire geek
um i got it right that time i think
people get sometimes a bit stressed
because if i if i say something on the
video and they disagree with me they get
very you know can get very tense but
you're wrong and i'm like good
tell me why
sometimes i swear to god i say things on
this channel that i know are wrong just
to get people to talk about it and i
don't do it on purpose but i don't know
i do i do it on purpose completely on
purpose um but i think it's interesting
to you know get a conversation going you
know and it's like and people don't seem
to
quite understand that
sometimes um
i think we've done these videos this
week you've done stupid are the aura
and i've done awesome of your own we've
done it very much on purpose but people
have got
really upset about it because they're
like well he's he's just been negative
and i'm just like
that's the point someone that
essentially called me an idiot
not in that that that word
yeah
essentially they've been quite a few
comments and it's got very
um
off topic let's say
yes
it was very much a video that was um
i knew
going into it i was i was supposed to
argue against the all right and i don't
really dislike them that much they're
all i mean they are stupid but
i i just came up with points that are
stupid
and argued it that was the point
yeah
that that's you know that's kind of the
point isn't it though that you know it's
like i i have an opinion and my opinion
changes sometimes as well i'll do a
video and then somebody will point out
you're wrong and i'm like i've got a
i've got i've got a point
and i was like i'm i i like to think i'm
reasonably open-minded and just because
i you know
you know just because i say something
doesn't necessarily mean well for when
it doesn't necessarily mean sometimes
i've just thought about it there and
then
and just said it
and then afterwards i'm like i don't
know why i said that's stupid but you
know it's but it's opinion isn't it it's
just conversation and it's like and
sometimes i want to get people talking
on the debate and and you know that's
that's kind of the point and you know
and sometimes though i say stuff and i
really mean it and people just agree
with me and i do get irritated but
they can do it
i mean sometimes you say things don't
you because you actually believe them
and then someone points something out
and then you change your mind like
that's just being human
that's bro that's just like you you can
be you can
have an intelligent conversation and be
wrong
yeah like
it's not it's not the end of the world
is it so also truth is a little bit of a
perspective in that um
it doesn't it's not always exactly that
you know it's it really does depend on
the way you're looking at it
we mean you can argue we can both be
right
yeah um
but it really depends on how you look at
it sort of thing
um
we've got a video coming out in a couple
of weeks where i'm arguing at the good
side
of
yeah i've let you be the good guy
something else i'm not going to tell you
what we're arguing about
yeah but i think you mentioned it really
oh did you
my good idea but yeah i'll talk about it
it's fine well it's the nice thing isn't
it about doing these videos together is
that we can do these little videos but
i've thought of a few more as well um
you know that we can we can we can put
both sides of the argument i do that you
do the tuesday video i do the thursday
video we can have different side of the
argument and we have to play devil's
advocate a little bit because you're
picking aside um but i come second so i
get to make you look stupid
i know because your videos on on the
next why why is the green screen acting
so weird
the next time
i'm definitely going to win because it's
yeah i was just
we'll see we will base it on who gets
the most views
and um for every view i get
over yours i get to hit you in the face
um so if i get 100 views more than you i
get a
100 free punches in there so there you
go guys
i'll drive down for that
i'll come to you
um we should base it on likes because
views might be a bit unfair she based on
likes who gets the most likes
wins
yeah
when we do that video that we're talking
about which is going to be about uh sgu
i'll i'll admit it because i did mention
earlier it's going to be sgu whoever
gets the most likes on the video there
will be a four fit for the other one
all right
and we wonder what the forfeit is you
know what to do
[Laughter]
you like most so we will have a forfeit
on the video and i tell you what
actually we will let
the people the lovely people in the
subscribers pick
the forfeit
all right all right can it be
shave your head
no because your bald is a cute and i'm
going that way
it might be shaved something else just
so much shaving my beard off there's no
way
oh that's not where i was going but i
can't grow a beard so that would be okay
with me i have a much even down there i
i think it might be
it might be an embarrassing
video
there or something i don't know we'll
think about it there you go right well i
can do embarrassing embarrassing's fine
yeah because i my my embarrassment died
a long time ago
i have no shame so we're good with that
go on guys get into the comments what do
you reckon we should do
as a friend yeah go on then first first
guy's coming with a decent idea what can
a forfeit be
right so to get back to stargate let's
have another quiz question but i'm going
and throw out two the lovely people in
the group let's let's see who can get
the answer on the comment first so let's
just go you say stop again so stop
stop
right
oh actor gary jones plays what part in
stargate sg-1 sergeant harryman the
technician norman davis or all of these
go get in the comments come on come on
who can type fastest guitar faster
so i will do a quick lin loser has to
get their chest waxed live on the stream
right how hairy are you
i mean not that
yeah you need it
so again
i wouldn't mind that too much how about
they get their book no i don't want to
see that
get your butt crack
one way to get your channel banned
so just to quickly say again actor gary
jones plays what part in sg-1 sergeant
harriman the technician norman davis or
all of these we have a winner
we i know who's who's already got the we
have a winner we have a winner we have a
winner
monkey sausage yep
you also win the prize of best youtube
name i thank you so much because your
name is monkey sausage club
and can i go in
that gives me joy
and i think we should all all join and
then fling poop
that's what monkeys do he is all of them
so actor gary jones played all of those
characters sergeant harriman the
technician norma davis he played all of
them it's a trick question
so well done guys give that five minutes
to another we'll have another go that i
enjoyed that
so also guys get to the comments i want
to know why people want stargate to
return
out of all of the tv shows that they
could
reboot and they are rebooted let's be
honest they're doing
um interview with the vampire tv series
eragon tv series
um oh god the list goes on and on
doesn't it i'm actually quite looking
forward to the aragon tv series actually
i think it might be quite good into the
vampire might be quite good as well but
um
i think that's the sunny side of
streamer services that i think projects
like that will work obviously lord of
the rings which people are getting very
angry about even though they've not seen
it yet
calm down
um
you know
recently
yes they dropped a trailer it's only
three minutes right is a good one
the loser would need to write a eulogy
for the winner and then record or read
live and post it on youtube eulogy
well as if as it so
did years if you're dead
i've got mine on that i said that sounds
like a laugh i could be a good one
um it's not very embarrassing i think we
could i think we can do better but it's
not bad is it i quite like that that'd
be a laugh yeah we'll stick it in the um
in the maybe bucket well it's it's 100
in the maybe bucket but keep going keep
going i bet he is now playing with his
monkey sausage
[Laughter]
he
might well he will be very excited and
very happy about it
so
jared has just come in star go such
great character story's always family
friendly i want to watch it in real life
i'm not phrased my little ones around
that is a nice
that is a nice way of looking at it
actually this is something it's one of
those shows i told my kids to watch
my lad likes sci-fi
and i'm trying to get him to write it my
dad's also a really good writer you know
i don't know if you remember guys but
i'm supposed to be writing a fanfiction
but i'm not very good at writing so i've
got a good idea for the story but he's
good at description and stuff so i'm
getting him to write it but he says i
need to i need to understand it so i'm
like great watch stargate then so i've
bullied him into watching starcate so
that he can rewrite my fan fiction for
me
um
so
loser has to get a tattoo on their ass
cheek
now okay now we're going up now now this
now we're getting there all right
are the commenters going to pay for it
they do pay for it through
advertisements
so i think that's what we started
what
okay so all right if we were because
this is a high stakes this is what would
you get my first story is the other
one's name
so not the other person's name but what
would we have tattooed on our ass if we
were to go with tattoo
because
i could have i love the aura and you
could have i love stargate universe
i'm going to make you have i love jamie
um what you could do is have a tattoo of
a handprint
tattoo on your backside
that'd be good
um so go on guys what what should we
have tattooed on our backside for the
loser oh jesus mate i really want my
video to be good
i'll tell you no i'm not getting a
tattoo
i should have i'm not on your butt cheek
have you got any tattoos
yeah i've got one so you say you don't
care then i've got an uh which side i've
got an enormous one so i'd i'd have a
tat
um
in the um
logo
tattooed on you on your arm or something
on your shoulder
[Music]
now you're tempted
and that's my um that's my this is for
my daughter
it's after her name because it's a type
of flower that she's named after so that
would be a bit difficult for me but i
could have it on my on my oh no
i could have it on my arm i could have
the home logo
i forgot where it was well i'm looking
at myself in the thing i don't know so i
i went the wrong way um it's mirrored uh
shelley i got a
babe i've got a massive tattoo that that
that took like five
times
robert knight just joined thank you very
much sir that is really really
appreciated you are a gentleman
o'neill on your nose
i'm not having a tattoo on my face
anything permanent
how about a ring around the ring
[Laughter]
monkey slaughtered you on fire tonight a
stargate around the
uh the iris is open
no yeah because the iris because the
area
there are times aren't there
something scared me my iris is well and
firmly closed
um
super chats to pay for it
then i will um
we will get this tattoo and i think the
loser
or the winner actually because i
wouldn't mind having it done gets oh
wrong arm again gets the
home
logo tattooed on your arm
and we'll film it
come on
[Laughter]
you would guess cool stargate tattoo and
your wife would have to do it because
it's a bet she'd have to let you do it
no
oh yeah a woman
oh there i
did happily do anything embarrassing
okay
i did do a video with him alad spencer
who's just a legend
and he we did it was about star trek
and he came on
and he by the end of the video he was
absolutely paralytic he was actually
falling off his we actually are pretty
sure he fell asleep at one point
um it's a brilliant video if we go back
and have a look at it it was um
his star trek
lost its way or something a very early
live video we did
um i'll clip it and put on later or
something and um but he'd what he'd done
was he'd done with um a pen and done all
the trill markings down his face down
his neck and it looked great
and but then as he's going through he's
going
it's a bit itchy sort of thing you
starting thing and i'm still like um and
then as he going through went ah
i was like what's wrong mate
i've done it with permanent marker
from the video it's like it's not coming
off
i'm panicking and you don't he drawn all
over himself with a permanent mark
we should do a drinking stream one day
i i mean i drink everything that's not
joke
no no
no i'm gonna buy a proper one we'd have
to
shots of something i don't know what
whatever your poison is
okay every time something happens it has
to be something that happens quite often
let's have stormy in the chat right yeah
and every time he goes off on a tangent
oh let's have a drinking game we're not
telling him um storm is not with us
because over in the u.s it's currently
half 12 and he's at work
so um
so i'm afraid he can't be with us
tonight i'll tell you what is again is
it it's a dick when we hit 20 000
subscribers
right
shelly she's added to our tattoo fun
thank you so much ellie you already do
so much for this channel i feel bad
taking your money but i will take it um
but um
yes pink gin um thank you so much and
yeah get in there right so
yeah we'll do a drinking um it's or
every time i say basically
neck
i say it a lot
um basically so but yeah we will have
when we hit ten thousand
twenty five oh that's what he's saying
is he finally gonna get i didn't even
read the full message
we had the same thoughts cynical at the
same time
um
when we hit twenty thousand if we hit
twenty thousand subscribers please if
you are new to channel i can subscribe
and hit the bell notification
hit likes share subscribe
watch the adverts all the way through
we need the money um
um
when we hit 20 000 subscribers
you're cheeky buggers
yeah all right i wave my hands around a
lot when i talk
sorry
i don't think any of these people have
noticed anything about me because i've
not been on that
i've not been here that long
yeah there's nothing they can say about
me yet
um that would get us arrested monkey
sausage
oh with a sandwich no
way
i i might do that anyway adrian
so um comic-con wales telford takeover
oh thank you so much thanks for the
great time to show guys hello to the uri
yes they are and yorkshire geek
you will return
so um i want to get you on a video i
don't get the adverts so actually you're
the person watching somebody we do get
money from um
i call girls dude what
this
calling girls dude
who's who did you call a dude oh a
cynical cloud is a girl i think
i'm sure she's corrected me before
actually told me
but anyway um
oh sorry calling girls dudes man
all right dude everyone's together
and they might be if people ask for it a
shut up matt t-shirt done you've already
designed it haven't you you're and
you're very we had that we had that
discussion on the live stream you said
it once and i was like i'm gonna make a
t-shirt so i did you did
so i might add it to the t-shirts
designs very shortly which you can get
from cydustrec.com
um
and cups and things
um but yeah i've got another t-shirt uh
design in the works as well
you have
we need everyone to become sidetrack
champions
yes we do if you could
join the channel that would be amazing
because that way we don't have to
advertise videos if we can earn enough
money
um cynical cloud yeah you keep calling
me sir dude
yeah
i don't know why
what does it look like
i don't know i call everybody sir
um
but but obviously cynical cloud i don't
know why it's the name
oh yeah
i said you said that you were right and
i said yeah i'm not thanks
i'm not bad thanks dude
but actually you can see from the
picture that you are a lady but i don't
know why it just seems like think ah
everyone's throwing in money at us at
the moment so i really appreciate it
guys it really does help the channel and
as i say you guys think i'm joking when
i say i need my wife to let me keep
doing this
i need my wife to let me keep doing this
i absolutely love coming on here i think
it's i started off as a hobby
because that's my sister's name zoe i
didn't know zoe uh my ex uh i have an
ex-girlfriend called zoe i didn't like
her but um
that's why
it's lovely to meet you i will remember
that zoe in future
thank you very very much
um
i made it to scitrick legend shelley you
don't even have to join me you are a
psychic legend so shelley joint
manages my facebook group
and um she went we went from having a
couple of hundred to over 1200
people on the on the facebook group
which again helps grow the channel and
that is all down to shelley because
she's an absolute legend and i stole her
from another room
uh
that's not helping me donate all the
money to life no
i need appropriate money
it's my spending money on me money
now i do
and it does help when i make i like
how much money have you made this month
you'll be enough
yeah
it depends how much of the shoes you
want to buy
[Laughter]
nice but it does it does help and it
does um you know it's it's i shouldn't
do this we don't do this for money do we
but at the end of that i want to make
the money off youtube but i don't want
to make a few people you know the people
but but if you like what we're doing and
you appreciate what we're doing it's a
nice way to show that support and and i
say oh it is actually quite expensive to
do a youtube channel this thing because
people moaned about my volume i had to
buy a new speaker and they're not cheap
but it's a good one so i just spent a
bit more money this time got a good one
right
exactly it seems to work right um
brad has written a script sir um
so
uh we we know it exists 100 brad's
written script he's done several
rewrites as well um and
mgm before the amazon deal went through
did a lot of work on
artwork and costing and everything they
even figured out how much this thing
would cost to make
and but then amazon
are not happy with um what they produced
basically
so
which is a shame
we are
we're only five minutes away
so guys
you need to start tweeting tweeting
get get twittering if you can tell you
don't
um i'll just say how many currently i've
got
97 notifications about people tweeting
twittering
we want to walk on tv show we want brad
we want brad if you just tweeted that
dear hamilton we are the fans of
stargate
brad wright is epic for the show runner
we want a continuation not a reboot
you're sincerely the fans did you do
that
excellent well done so i'm gonna start
tweeting now while we're on
hashtag give us uh stargate or we will
hurt you
i'm gonna just post quickly the um
the twitter account that i'm using
it's not my personal twitter account
it's just it's just for this campaign so
if you want to come and you know follow
it
retweet it you know
yeah
do so what will be um we want brad
we want brad
you already follow it
yeah i know i was just tweeting
ah i can't tweet
i have to do hashtag first don't i
we want
stargate so if you don't follow us
already it's tv underscore sci
if you are on twitter and if you don't
hate twitter i i hate twitter
um
i don't hate twitter it's just limits me
what i'm allowed to say and i'm that
annoys me but then we gotta do it while
um uh it still exists because there's
an elon musk suing them
stargate st
one i just gotta pick an image
i'm gonna do the uh my my favorite low
t-shirt logo i'm sending that
um let's do one more
this is fascinating um
uh television i know
but you guys should all be doing the
same thing you should be tweeting
immediately
so i send a picture of my t-shirt and
the advert no that's that's just crap in
it i can't do that
uh it's a bit crass in it
um
just a stargate image there we go
so we are tweeting people and then i
will get in there and start irritating
sci-fi nerd join at oh iritis
iritis wraith thank you you've
posted on our to join the um
the the
coved
the discord server thank you so much get
in there
gateworld not my favorite people in the
world at times but they're tweeting like
crazy
stargate now
is you
wake me up if at amazon green lights
canon
just retweet it like crazy guys get in
there start doing it now this is where
we need to start doing it
because we want this damn show back but
we don't just want it
now we want it right
and that's the important thing we don't
want them to rush this and actually to
be fair to amazon they genuinely seem to
not want to rush it either they they
they are taking their time they could
have done this and made people really
happy really quickly
but they're not they're taking the time
and
if anything else i i appreciate that
they're taking their time
um i just put if they actually get off
their backsides and do something about
it
because it's no longer you know it's
this i think the longer we wait
the um
the more likely a um
hard reboot is
yeah
and that's what we've got because we're
getting older and stuff aren't they so
yeah we don't we don't i think we're
going to get a soft reboot we're not
going to get we might get
we might get general carter actually i
think pretty sure if brad wright gets
his way we're getting general carter
um
but you know
oh
i like that andrew
yeah
um i i want to be an airman
um i don't i don't
let's not say i don't have a beef with
stargate or with gateworld i don't have
a beef with them i don't like
maybe
well for one they have actually had a
little dig at me started start start
tweeting it start tweeting go go go go
go they have a little dig at me once or
twice um and um because i i share things
that maybe i shouldn't or they think i
shouldn't um but i say if i have
something to room i tell you it's a
rumor i'm not a giant freaking robot i
tell you things genuinely where they've
come from
and i've had a little i've had a few
little digs at me
so um but you know i
uh learn meridievoir um
he's the one that started this he did a
lot of work i'm talking about me taking
credit
uh sebastian deserves a lot of credit
because he has been talking about months
about having this we want stargate
getting going so um
that's his channel midi of r he is
french if you don't understand french
you're gonna struggle but um he's an
absolute legend and he works really
really hard
um
and he loves stargate i mean look at him
with his pn19 everything uh so we're
getting loads and loads and loads ah
shelly is getting in there tweeting well
done
um kirsty our stargate now
underscore eu he's been a supporter of
the channel for a long time she's always
commenting she's on the facebook group
she's she's a big supporter of stargate
um christie's is everywhere if you
follow stargate at all on twitter you'll
know kirsty's um uh
face her name
um but everything is getting on there
now it's really great this is it's
really nice to see
are we streaming yet come on we must be
we must be on that list by now
oh yeah
uh
how long behind is it
um amazon is too big they shows follow
trends
which i don't think fits target at all
it's a show that needs to stick to its
own recurring and familiar scenery
i don't know about that
choppy to be honest i but because i
think it's one of those shows that to be
honest if amazon really did want to make
political statements it's the sort of
show that you could
um
and it does it can change but so
maybe maybe not
um
bob's thing i've got a format in mind
maybe multi-long seasons i guess g1 or
like standard alone seasons of eight
episodes i can tell you that from what
i'm told
they're going to do standard streaming
service um series it'll be 10 or 12
episodes but we might get two or three
seasons a year
of different
books a bit more a bit like how they do
with star wars with the book of boba
fett how we get like two or three
seasons a year that are
interconnected
but
maybe different perspectives on a
different story and or different teams
and
off world or whatever um
i have been told
recently
that the um idea about doing a prequel
where it's the ancients which i said um
mgm were looking at uh about six months
ago
um has been backstrong in their office
again that's apparently been
one of the things that has been
discussed about how about if we just get
rid of all this kind of stuff how about
if we just do a prequel
and we do it that way um because i
genuinely don't think they actually know
how or what to do
from what i'm told
from people like say that working around
this
the main reason amazon is stalling is
because they don't actually know how to
do it
they're not sure what to do i prefer
would be would be a good idea
i think even if it's not something long
term just just having it
because you can you can there's so many
stories that we don't know about the
ancients
yeah but we
everyone loves the ancients and if you
don't you don't like stargate
because they are the gateholders they
are they are the very at the very core
of what stargate is they
you know
yeah learning more about them it's
basically that's that's why atlantis was
so that's we're in the city of the
ancients
that came with that
but having them
that would be brilliant
i'd like to see janus again
you know the guy who break the time
machine yeah okay well the stargate can
be a time machine as well so
apparently
main thing i'm worried about is they do
six episode long with one story like
they do with most city shows nowadays i
know it's a long bigger budget but i
prefer a full season the sad thing is i
don't think we're going to get a 24
episode season because can you name a
single series on streaming in the last
five years that's done 20 episodes
they just don't um
a couple of reality shows maybe they've
done longer but normally they're 10 12
episodes aren't they
and that's all we get
so
um
not necessarily about
if we don't get as many because we can
there won't be as much fluff
yeah if they do it that way so there'll
be no filler episodes no clip shows
nothing like that i know some people do
enjoy those but people
will come for the stories more
yeah
i think so i agree with you that's what
we want
um how are we getting on what's your
twitter looking like
uh everyone's tweeting
yeah i'm the wii u once target hashtag
everyone's tweeting at least
once a second
i get um so i'm getting thinking about
retweets and things i've had another 70
notifications
i had 93 notifications when i looked a
second ago when they're all
either likes
yeah my likes and retweets haven't
stopped all day
yeah
which is excellent um
continuation i'm going to sign that
replying to side.tv kirsty again
um
yeah it's great so
i say we're not gonna know if this has
worked for a day or two i can't tell you
that i will get my ear to the ground as
soon as um you know
they get out um but obviously the people
i speak to are all in america so they
don't finish work until from like four
hours
shelly i'm gonna do a video on the
muppets
only because
shelly will come on and we all get to
meet her um our little canadian shelly
and she just really really wants to talk
about the muppets
like a lot
so
so you're coming on one day shelly we
are going to get you on to talk about
the muppets and i love the
i love the muppets to be honest i want
to
see
space
that's good
actually
a prequel set during the time of the
ancients
otherwise the gold would be acceptable
um so long as brad and joseph malozio at
the helm
that's sidetracked
yeah the idea with the gold's not a bad
idea as well because i'd love to see
um ra
he's the only system we never really saw
we saw him in the movie and we saw him
in origin but we never saw him in the
actual tv show i don't count origins as
an actual tv show
um
no yeah yeah i think that i don't think
any of this would mind if they're just
pretending that didn't happen when they
i think would it go old prequel then
would work
if they just do a goal ruled show from
like
say a thousand years ago when we see
ra's rise to power
yeah
but
i don't think i think it should have
some of the current you know the actors
that we we know and love now like some
sort of time travel kind of thing so
they they they're they're in that time
but they're experiencing it and that's
how they can get around it
and i don't think just having a global
would be a good idea well apparently
amazon kept banging on at mgm about this
is one of the reasons why apparently
they've pulled everything because
they're just saying apparently they kept
telling them they kept asking the mgm
what they wanted to do they were just
doing the just going their own way and
that's why they got irritated
but one of the things they wanted to do
is just like this multi-platform thing
where they would have
they got the game timekeepers coming out
they've got they wanted to make a couple
of movies they want to do a couple of tv
series they wanted all these things to
intertwine then they wanted a
multi-platform thing and i was told look
at what the storyline for timekeepers is
that will be integral to where the tv
shows go and the timekeepers is a time
travel
series it jumps around
if they do these 10 episode
little mini series almost but they how
they all interlock each other so we'd
still get 30
30 episodes a year they'd just be split
up a little bit
um
i could completely see that and i could
see them doing
a 10 episode thing where yeah they go
back in time and they
meet raw they go and they go save eli
and that that's that'll be the core bit
of that one chunk of story and then you
know but we could have different teams
we could have it would be you know
i i think they could do lots and lots of
things with this
um and we could have but the nice thing
as well is we can have a movie
and the actors from the movie could
easily appear in the tv series nowadays
that is there's no problem at all about
that with them in
a um a streaming service nowadays
because the the budget's allowed for it
sort of thing
um
i i did see a rumor that it was i've
just said this has not been
substantiated by anything i've been told
i think it's i think it's probably
rubbish but again it was giant freaking
robot that um liam hensworth was gonna
do the movie
and it would totally be soon that he
could then if he did the movie he could
he could appear in the series easily
and
so that's another bonus of streaming
but um
i'm not even sure why um amazon
would want to do a movie
no it's going to go straight to
i know there's still a prestige of a
movie
people get really excited about movies
but it's going to go straight to amazon
really it's just like a long episode of
an episode why not just do the series i
don't know why they they bother
so they did it with um
borat didn't they the second bora
because of lockdown they they put
the whole movie onto amazon
but did it actually do well
i don't know
like i watched it because i like borat
but
i've never watched it again
um
um these things they don't and the
movies
i say people will get excited about a
movie but straight to dvd is straight to
amazon movie it doesn't get the hype
that a movie the cinema does people
aren't talking about it you know that
like the chris pratt movie the aliens
one that was pretty good and it got
adverse i didn't even know it was coming
out until about a week before
and movies though i know about months
before you know it's like
it you know happens you know you get a
lot of hype you get a lot of depressed
junk and stuff they just that just
doesn't happen for straight to amazon
movies so i don't really understand the
argument
of them saying they want to do it as for
that big bang to start the series i
don't think they need to
um i think they can be just as just as
good just just hitting us with a series
but
yeah
they get serious people as well
yeah
um i've heard tom over midnight air to
talk about how you heard amazon wants to
bring the original cast back for a top
gun style movie and just more being
jealous for this yeah that story was
posted on giant freaking robots first
um it's it's it's almost certainly not
true but
um even from my sources telling me that
it's been considered
and this is going back five six years to
be fair it was considered last time but
i'm being told
kurt russell could return as a cameo for
a movie
james spade has no chance
so it wouldn't be the original cast
maybe kurt russell
and apparently he would be interested
is what i'm being told
but they need to decide what they're
doing first and that's why these stories
are nonsense because the truth is amazon
don't know what they're doing if they
did not they were doing they'd have
announced it
because they announced everything
um and then what they like to do is then
keep it all secret but they lord of the
rings was announced
2018
that they would that it was happening
and they had to i was supposed because
they spent 500 million they can't really
hide that off the books company
so what have you just spent 500 million
on nothing
why are the tolkien families so happy we
don't know
they've all just bought boats
it's got nothing to do with that shut up
um
but but yeah so
i i i
the end of the day
amazon are going to do this they are
it's it's what they do
and who is in charge of it that we have
to be worried about and personally i
think brad wright should be in charge i
think we need new writers in the new
direction and new blood to make it
interesting but i think brad wright will
make them stick to canon and i think he
should be in charge
um
but i'd like to see young writers
somebody with some new i'd like to see
some new ideas in there because so long
has gone between sg-1 ending and is it
15 years now since
um sgu finished
isn't it 11 years since yesterday 11
years so you're right it's 10 it's 10
years 10 15 years since sg1 finished
um 11 years since then so i mean that's
11 years it's over a decade
you know they they they will they will
neutrak this they just will
um i think the most likely thing is that
like we discussed on the last video is
there'll be a hybrid it'll be
a mix of canon and new
and that's how they'll do it i think i
think
they can stick
you know the idea he said will be the
time keepers thing
if they are jumping between timelines
if they involved like the original not
the original cast but like it's a cast
from now
going back in time they can still keep
it in canon because they could basically
make it be like oh
the stargate malfunction mouse function
we went back five six thousand years
yeah and we accidentally just made the
gold the most powerful villain in the
universe in the galaxy
yeah like
we are that we are the reason but we
only just found out we are the reason
and it could still be can
like we are the humans that are on the
beach
you know next to the unes and they were
like hang on let's try the let's try the
humans rather than unis and then ra was
like i like the humans let's go find out
where they're from and that's how it
started
i like it why not that we find out we're
all the reason why
everything that went wrong in the galaxy
was because we're stupid it was because
of us harris um i've just seen harris's
on our uh in the messages check your um
messages on twitter please
so yeah i'd love that idea um i'll just
say that like i have
another 90 notifications on my twitter
you can obviously it resets every time i
look
with retweets
comments
um
right you give a stargate or i feed one
of my i always feed you one of my
friends
i feed you one of your friends
sorry that's just funny pop770
you give a stargate or i feed one of
your friends to you
that's god
but hey why not
um so
let's get into oh i got a guy commenting
on your video from earlier
um you know the name
you know your video is called stupid
other all right his comment was how to
ensure people don't watch your video
it'd be insulting in your title pass
so my response was how am i insulting
it's an ancient made-up god
how who am i inside of my insulting
oh no i'm in nothing of fictional
character
referring to anything is stupid when
talking creative defeats your own
argument all the points in that video
will just be as immature you're immature
matthew
which you are so oh no
i know right um
where's this comment i can't even see it
uh it's on you it's on facebook
i shared your video on facebook
well
facebook
i was going to try and get harris to
come and join us but he's at the gym so
we do what do we want to see is sweaty
harris
yes
yes then in that case i don't want to
but no we're not going to be on much
longer harris because um i've got work
tomorrow
so but let's have a couple more
questions to see who can get into the
ready stop
stop
okay
always a good one
up until the end of season six
season six
samantha carter has had how many love
interests go
i think you did you you gave i think i
did this in the last one and i got it
completely wrong
joke how do you piss off a vegan turn
them into a vampire
i this was one of the questions in the
uh
and you know what even though
we don't remember the answer yeah is
there anything wrong
zoe is wrong
oh jared you're wrong my friend
i thought was about come from because
this is where vampires come from
come on
as somebody's got to get this question
right
see six seasons so we're talking six
years
hugo susan you are also wrong sir
i feel i could go higher higher lower
lower
um you go lower
come on first one to get in cynical
cloud zoe nun i'm afraid that's not the
right answer either
and none of them would um jack
sorry jack
smokey sausage sorry jack it's quite a
few
um i don't know if all of them were
sexual partners
oh
here we go
popeye all popeye is correct it was five
there were five love interests by the
end of season six i think it was only
six overall by the end of the
thing buzzy you're wrong should jack
count is the question no
because i'm yes there was the
um
mirror universe um one cynical cloud zoe
69
69
andrew wrong the answer was five the
answer was five
um she's a black widow first there was
jonas hansen who appeared in the first
commandment he fell to his death then
there was no rim who first appeared in
enigma he lasted quite a while before
sam left to blow up
left him to blow up along with the rest
of the planet and of course there was
martuff who appeared in the first of the
tokra she later shot and killed him then
came ambassador joe faxon who first
appeared in the 2010 episode in the 2010
episode she left him to die with the
ashan finally there was orlan who was in
ascension where who
re-ascended after getting shot
now i know pete exists in season seven
starting with chimera but something's
got to happen to him this is an older
quiz by the way um jack and sammy to end
up together
yeah because pete shot him within season
seven wasn't he
complete black widow i'm gonna give you
another question the game
oh so good didn't pete die
no i think she just left him didn't she
she really realized she loved anneal and
just sort of left him to drilling
um but yeah let's let's get him shot as
well why not um the game keeper played
by dwight schultz held his people
captive on the reasoning that they would
destroy his precious garden until sg1
came along
um i think that might be the answer
yeah and i've just read the answer
with multitude where neil and carter are
standing on a nice planet which is
really in the antarctic how many times
according to o'neill has he previously
broken a bone
ooh
how many times has o'neill broken a bone
according to that we broke a few more
didn't you because he there's a story
about how he tripped over his um
daughter's uh he was carrying his
daughter and tripped over the stair
and broke his leg and then you actually
see him in the show with a bust-up knee
and it's because it was real he'd
actually bust his knee
so how many times had he broken a bone
random guesses
zoe no get rabba no
i'm afraid you are wrong
i need a proper answer though don't we
through
yeah de luise play pete
yes
hugo susa and adrian those came in
virtually identically it is nine bones
we have some proper fans in well done
because matt didn't know that he didn't
know that in the quiz either i didn't
monkeys
as well
um we did ask that question yeah you got
it wrong oh
see
even though so when you do when you do
these questions and then you tell me the
answer i will still forget and not know
the answer
uh one more question before we
we wrap up for this evening a constant
enemy throughout the early stages early
years of the stargate program this gold
was finally killed an encounter with the
replicators
who was he oh i i love this guy
so what was the answer you can say do
you know it's a prophet shut up matt
everybody it was a prophet how many
times did we see apophis die
three
i think it was three yeah i'm not sure
now i'll ask the question i'm not sure
the answer to it
um the first time he died was actually
generally heartbreaking
like oh my god was a really good actor
because didn't he
no he didn't ignore me i was gonna say
yeah yeah he did he got shot in the
knocks planet didn't he
was that one
no he didn't die that time no he died
when his um
finger then he went to hell i think he
might have only been twice actually
he then he went to hell so he died on
the and the earth and then we sent his
body back through the gate didn't we
instead of alveol
satan will just
reanimate him in this sarcophagus and um
and kill him again and torture him and
then we see him he's taken over satan
and we see him and he's come and then
yeah the last time we see him properly
is he's got all that metal on his face
and he
and he's got um and the replicators are
climbing over
here's the question how many times did
um the replicators actually do we
actually see them kill anyone on screen
once in the movie
he the replicators don't kill him oh i
suppose they do
terminator
they did turn him into the terminal yeah
i would say that's the only time but i
well you'd argue whether he's dead or
not but yeah they take over his body
don't they and they i don't think he's
feeling very well with a replicator
something of the host survives fairly
into the back of his head yeah but um
other than that we never see
a
terminator a a replicator actually kill
anyone there's always a door closed then
you hear screaming from the other ah
spiders and then daniel jackson legging
it because he genuinely couldn't be
michael shanks apparently couldn't be in
the um
in the in the visuals with the wither
their little model replicators he
couldn't do xxxim horribly
um
he's a massive arachnophobic yeah
so
i will have just one more look at my
twitter
it's a shame harris couldn't come join
i like harris he's funny he's too
good-looking i'm a bit concerned how
good-looking he is and i have an own
livestream and he's too young as well so
he makes us me and stormy look stupid on
a sunday when he keeps joining us
that's right i've got someone who's
he's not he's not anywhere near my age
to be fair but he's closer than you are
dude that's harsh
i've got another 45 mentions or retweets
most of my retweets
so guys we are getting in there
can you see us on the list are we
trending
ah
no i'd love to get an announcement
that's not true ah i always like that
story because i'm arachnophobic it
actually didn't make sense to me to be
fair because i think that they were all
cgi anyway weren't they
uh but that's a shame that story's not
true
[Music]
i really want to get a
3d printed um
replicator
okay you know that's how
um bad things start all right because
that's basically what we did
in the movie we printed one and then
they took over that
i don't want one that actually works oh
okay just checking just checking let's
check in
right kev is going to go grab a beer i
am going to go and grab my wife i know
there's a little bit more information
you need but i've actually not seen her
all day i literally walked in 10 minutes
before this video started so i need to
go give my wife a cuddle but guys
let's hope that we have given amazon a
royal kick up the backside
um you've all got on to
um
twitter for us and i'd say tweeting like
crazy thank you so much
um
i appreciate everybody that's commented
today and i'd laugh um as soon as matt
loses our bet he's getting a tattoo
which will be fun
and um you
woman i'll get tattooed
we're going to get very
very drunk when we hit twenty thousand
then right okay
should we get twenty thousand
can we do it we hit eleven thousand
because that's pretty close
we're only a couple hundred from that
in like three days
tell you what when we hit 15 000 should
we get drunk
should we just get drunk every 5 000
subscribers
that's gonna get really awkward if we if
we ever go viral and get 100k
um you guys tell us what should we do
every i
will do when we hit 15 000 just for fun
because it'll it'll be a nice thing
since you've joined the channel as well
all right so fifteen thousand we will do
a pissed up
and thing where you have to start
drinking at least a couple of hours
before the video starts because you need
to be half cup before it starts all
right
and then
when we hit
if ever we hit 50 000 subscribers
i pledge to you now that you will have
to remind me if i put you now i will
get wrong
i will get stargate home logo or
whatever you guys want tattooed on my
arm all right i'm not getting
sidetracked tattooed on my arm but i
will get
a stargate thing
and shelley's a whiskey girl
she is going to get drunk with us
um so that is awesome so
fireball shots
why not and then we will have to think
of some sort of drinking game
i'll just get hammered
so there you go we will do that when we
hit 15 000 just for fun
so please let's subscribe
your quiz book i've just thought of a
drinking game but i know it just means
i'm gonna get bladdered
yeah
you do your quiz and every question you
get wrong you take a shot
zoe sweet not if if if we hit 50 000
subscribers
if
i will get a tattoo on my arm but i will
film it and put it on the channel
i'll tell you what i'll get
is i'll get the thingy thingy and 50k
tattooed on my arm
all right when we hit 50 000.
all right
if you need to tell your friends over
there with me gang oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah right
thank you very much guys
please continue twittering
or tweeting or
birding whatever it's called and on get
on there put on there
have a ball with it and let's get this
damn show thingy um i think i must be
drunk now because matt has gone all
blurry again
i don't know
at least uh is my audio okay at least
yeah it's all grounded me so we've got
half an hour left of the tweet storm so
let's just tweet
just keep going keep going keep going
keep going
um i'm sorry i've gone very dark by the
way but i forgot to get my lights set up
because i didn't have time but
you can still see me blue
um i'm getting creepy
as i'm running i should have been
under the thing hello
have a lovely evening guys keep
twittering if you're in the united
states you've got all day if you're in
the uk you've got a couple of hours go
to bed go get up in the morning
uh don't be crazy if you are andrew it's
like five in the morning
um so thank you so much um my
back screen is going crazy because it
must be time to go should we have one
more question before we go
yeah you have one more question
oh
right here's a good one and actually
this is good
uh how much does it cost to run the
stargate program and i think this was
said in the episode politics
how much does it cost to run
it's 4 30 in the afternoon where
shelling is
how much does it cost to run the
stargate program
this is another one you asked me this
once before and i can't remember and you
said a ridiculous number
as well it's like 25 quid
i said like 5 billion but it's slightly
less than that i think
i'm telling you what andrew has just i
don't know how close do we get i think
andrew deserves an honorable mention
next is pretty bloody close
but i think we've got enough people here
42 people watching the moment that we
can get their right answer 69 million
i'm afraid to be zoe i'm afraid it to be
um
it cost nearly a billion dollars to turn
the lights on
it does nowadays
i will give you a clue
andrew is bloody close
or you've gone a bit too low but you're
you're in between
i'll give you the answer because it
never happened it cost 74.4 billion
dollars annually to run the stargate
program according to i'm pretty sure it
was kinsey
in the um politics episode
so there you go
oh hugo is close 7.7 but now 7.4 billion
dollars
so guys thank you so much for joining
matt thank you for joining um thank your
wife for letting you join because that's
appreciated and i will get everyone
thank my wife for letting me join as
well
keep twitter
i will see you all very very soon say
goodbye matt goodbye matt next up matt
thank you there
i'm sorry go on say goodbye man
goodbye matt
bye man
thank you all guys
have a lovely day evening and we will
see you at the weekend and go watch my
video tomorrow make sure it gets more
likes and views than mats did on tuesday
thanks guys see you later bye
[Music]
you